hello guys I'm Greg Alva and I'm John
well we're gonna watch today the cars
three teaser trailer number two oh boy
there's a second one I loved the first
teaser trailer that was dark it was
moody oh it's very surprised I'm hoping
this isn't similar vein to that one this
is the direction I was always hoping the
Cars franchise would go yeah excellent
you know darker more realistic dark
night baby I want this to be like a like
a inspirational sports movie about
Lightning McQueen overcoming paralysis
that sounds like a great idea John thank
you
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] later oh [ __ ]
[Music]
Oh No
Jackson storm he's a black car okay oh
we're gonna get a whole new whole new
variety of cars here it's the
Transformers now yeah making it ensemble
CRS
[Music]
my girl looks like a girl
[Music]
Cruz Ramirez you're in this Madhukar
this you Hanako what happen assuming
there we go
[Music]
car jack reacher would drive pad or the
car dwayne johnson would be yeah
[Music]
they're building this movie up in a
really weird way the thing is that this
is the way to hook me cuz I know like a
lot of people didn't love the original
cars three teaser because it is so like
whoa dark
honestly like I didn't even see cars to
like I like the first cars and even
though I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing I'm hooked by this I'm
like yeah cuz everyone looks different I
hope I hope that this is going to be
something very different
but this level of promotion they're
doing like the first teaser trailer be
not dark and serious this one having
like a badass vibe of introducing two
new cars
Jackson storm who sounds like a black
guy and Cruz Ramirez who sounds like a
Hispanic guy and lightning McQueen's the
white guy diversity Disney's all about
their diversity these days so yeah we
got to get an Asian car in there you
know like Donnie Chan what you did it's
clever I just hope they don't have super
racist personalities I think Larry the
Cable Guy is the ultimate stereotype for
like southern hick I know and I hope
this is I hope the cars that are
introducing aren't just stereotypical
personalities of these guys well yes yes
that's what this has me curious about is
now like these both of these clearly
look like they're at least adding more
real stakes and a more real flair to
their world and right now we don't even
know we don't know who does we don't
even know who they are character is the
only one credited on IMDB is Owen Wilson
is lightning McQueen maybe the Wikipedia
page has a bit of information here it's
good of cast yes
cristela Alonzo female Hispanic car yeah
oh Jackson's storm is actually played by
Armie Hammer interesting interesting
great chance to have a black character
and you totally ruined it I don't know
if that car was necessarily like
supposed to be black like it's it's a
car but but yeah that could have been an
opportunity I know but cristela Alonzo
a stand-up comedian his yes again
stand-up comedian I think she I think
that's cool we're gonna get a Mexican
car and there well yeah and her could
you have way to have higher all it
should have been a muscle car there's
already you mean she should have been
cheating badass Mexican car I see
hydraulics rough engine you know hey
embrace diversity I hope I just don't
watch him like that was conventional I
hope you wanted to be like they really
did something different with this movie
the thing is I feel like now it's an
interesting playing field they can't
give us another cars movie based on this
like you know if they give us another
Cars movie it's gonna I feel like
that'll be very very strange because
this is perhaps just the edgiest in tone
anyway that Pixar has given us and it
seems like maybe they're taking this
opportunity to be like people really
complain a lot about this particular one
of our franchises so hey we're gonna
bring something new something new to it
alright oh yes are you guys excited put
your comments down below are you excited
alright rejects it for new to the
channel you can subscribe today and get
accepted as we accept anyone who
subscribed Glock you if you're too
offensive in the comments Sam John's
John is reason to GRE on Twitter and
Instagram and he is a social media
manager of facebook.com slash blue house
and the real rejects the [ __ ] people on
you now are the ones getting shoutouts
the ones who are donating the high bars
Ali C one two three one two three five
thousand bars Thank You Ali C thank
greatly appreciate that anyone who
donates on you now it's all going back
and in production value of the real
rejects if you want to do more sketches
better or photos we have a couple of
things written up and we also want
better coma for our live streams too
because we need better live streams Ali
C this is your shoutout Ali I think
that's a beautiful name I would love to
meet you in an alley one day so you know
no I have no idea redo that alright
I meet somebody in an alleyway I look uh
I'd love to take my car down you're our
all of these going okay I like the third
time's a charm alley cat alley Cali can
you're on a groovy sexy cat pixie diag
pussycat